Hello everyone. So before we get into
the video, as I've done with the
previous videos up until the end of the
month, I will be giving a bond away for
every video that I do. So if you guys
want to know, as soon as those go live,
make sure to subscribe. And on top of
that, if you guys want to be entered
into the giveaway for this video, as
well as the rest of my videos to come,
make sure to leave a comment with your
RS name down in the comments below. And
on top of that, like the video and
subscribe to the channel to be entered.
But with that said, let's go ahead get
on into the video. Basically, this is
going to be a money-making method that
is just I mean, it's kind of it's kind
of something you can do on the side. A
lot of people like to merge and do
dailies and whatnot, and this is going
to be something that you can kind of tag
along with that as you go. After this
video, it probably won't even be
profitable, so don't do it right after
this. Uh, some of this stuff just
doesn't even have enough margin, but he
does do a lot of different things. So,
we'll get into it. Uh, before I go ahead
and get on into it, though, Psycho Ray
was the guy who actually told me this
method. So, shout out to him. Huge
thanks and I appreciate it so much, man.
But, let's go ahead and get on into the
requirements for this method. What we
are going to I guess we'll we'll say
what we're doing first. So, uh, mostly
harmless, basically a, uh, an island
that you can go to if you have some of,
uh, some of the prerequisites, I guess.
Um, this is where you're going to want
to go. There is a guy called Captain
Jack, I do believe, that like lingers
around right here, and that's where
we're going to want to be going. Now,
there is some other stuff I have to say
before this, and there are some
requirements. So, cabin fever going to
be a requirement that you're going to
need. Now, this does have a chain of
quests before it, so it's not
necessarily the easiest requirement.
some of the stuff that is included in
the requirements for cabin fever 42
agility 45 crafting 50 smithing and 40
range not that bad but some of the
prerexs of it uh some of the other
quests like for example rum deal you
have to have 42 crafting 50 fishing 40
farming 47 prayer so really all around
just a pretty well balanced account I
would say at least enough to be able to
finish cabin fever and then upon ending
that quest you get a book of piracy now
if you don't actually have this on you
or in your bank and you've completed the
quest if you want to go ahead and get
another one go to your player owned
house and it will be in your bookshelf.
It'll be like nine pages back. So, just
keep looking, but you'll find it. So,
what this allows you to do is go to
Captain Jack and what this guy will do.
All right, this guy's name is Patchy. I
don't know why I thought it was Captain
Jack. I apologize. But anyways, what
this guy will do is he will combine some
stuff for you. And mostly this comes in
the form of clue scroll type items. A
few examples of these to start. A
cavalier mask, as you guys can see, is
pretty much just what you would expect,
a cavalier and a mask. This can be
brought together by using a highway
man's mask and a cavalier on each other
through patchy. On top of that, you can
do the monle and top hat, which will
give you a top hat and monle. And you
can do a blue party hat and spectacles
of some sort. Obviously, you're going to
have to buy these sigacious ones. And
these do cost a little bit of money. So,
this is what I'm going to show you guys.
Basically, I ended up buying five, I
believe, for this price. So, we have
five that bought for 1.611 mil. And then
I actually bought some more the other
day for 1.555
mil. Um, so if we go ahead and look,
basically we can see how many I ended up
buying the other day. I think it was
somewhere around seven. Yeah, as you
guys can see. So I bought six the other
day and then five in this offer. So I'm
going to go ahead and find out what that
is in total. So in total, I spent 17.386
mil on all of these spectacles. So
that's 11 in total. Not too bad. Now if
we go ahead, we're just going to insta
buy some party hats. I wouldn't
recommend normally into buying, but for
the sake of the video, I'm just going to
do it. So, we're going to go ahead get
11 blue party hats and then we'll just
combine them together. I guess I'll go
ahead and wait for those to buy while I
end up talking about the other
investment that we have, and that is top
hats and spectacles or top hats and
monicles. So, as you guys can see, 125k
for each of the top hats. I do believe I
have a couple more in my bank here.
Yeah, as you guys can see, another three
in the bank. So, and as you guys can see
here, 1 mil and 1k in total for all the
top hats. So, ran into a little bit of
trouble. Basically, one thing I'll
recommend to you guys, buy your P hats
and your monicles or whatever you're
buying, try to buy them in advance. One
thing that I did is I waited to buy my P
hats and I waited to buy my monlesicles
because I thought, well, they're they're
cheap enough, you know, I'll just buy
out however many I need. They're like 8k
each. You can only buy five per 4 hours
per account. Luckily enough, I have a
few accounts, so I was able to spare all
that time. But for you guys, highly
recommend you don't do that. So, in
total, basically, monicles I ended up
buying for about 9k each for half of
them and about 4 1/2k each for the other
half. And then as far as P hats go, uh,
a little over 5k per one. So in total, I
spent 17.386 mil on the spectacles. I
spent 60k on all of the blue P hats. I
spent 56k on all the monles. And I spent
1 mil and 1k on all the top hats. So in
total, that comes out to pretty much
18.5 mil on the dot spent in total to
get all this stuff. And as you guys can
see before, I've actually, well, it was
just a little bit ago, I was able to
sell off a party hat in specs for 1.7
mil almost. So, there is definitely like
a 90k or an 80k margin on spectacles
depending on when you got them. Uh, for
me, the ones that I bought for 1.6 mil
are going to be, you know, like 90k
margins and the one I bought for 1.5 mil
will be like 140k margin. So, definitely
really nice. Now, if we go ahead and
look at the price of a top hat in Monle,
we'll be able to see how much money
we'll actually be able to make here. As
you guys can see, can't even buy for
207k, which is definitely a good sign.
Going to go ahead and try at my cash.
250k maybe. Then, okay, 228k still good
overall. all. I mean, with the monle and
the top hat, that's like 90k profit on
those as well. Yeah, even back here, as
you guys can see. I mean, yeah, pretty
much. I mean, we we'll be making about
90k on each one of these. So, that's
going to be insane. Keep in mind, I only
bought these overnight. That didn't even
take me that long to do. I mean, I could
have been doing this for a lot longer, I
guess. So, once you have an inventory of
all the items you're going to want to
take, go ahead and find your way to
mostly harmless in some way. I'm going
to go there with a teleport scroll
since, you know, they're pretty cheap
and it's definitely a lot faster than
most of the alternatives that I have.
So, if we go down here, as you guys can
see, there is Patchy. So, just right
click and then go to sew. He says, "I
charge 500 per item." And, uh, I guess
if you're like me, that means you're
going to go ahead and just grab some
cash. Now that you're over here, just go
ahead and have him sew your things for
you. If you go on the next page, this is
where you're going to find some of the
newer stuff that might be able to make
you a little bit of money. So, here you
just go and buy one, and then just keep
doing the same thing over and over, and
hopefully he doesn't go too far from
you. I'm going to go ahead and see how
long it takes me to do this. Should be a
couple minutes, but not too bad at all.
All right, folks. I absolutely scuffed
it. So, uh, I just finished recording my
outro, but apparently wasn't recording.
So, I got to go back through this entire
thing and just try to recap my steps. I
know it's going to be a little hard, but
bear with me. So, let me go and find
this real quick. As you guys can see on
screen now, minute and 53, that's how
long it took me. Luckily enough, still
had that up. So, minute and 53 is how
long it took me to sell off all of these
items. And then in total, if we go and
look at what I end up selling them for,
uh, basically you guys are going to be
in for a little bit of a shock. So, as
we saw earlier, I sold off a party hat
and specs earlier for $16.98. Uh, just
one a GP lower in case. And on top of
that, we have the top hat and specs that
are selling for 228K, which we saw
earlier is, you know, a capable price.
So, in total, 1.824K
right here, or 1.824 mil, I mean, and
then on top of that, over in the party
hat and specs, we have 18.677
mil. Now, in total, you guys remember we
spent 18.5 mil on all these items. So
just here alone we made 200k and then
over here this is all profit 1.8 mil. So
in total that's I mean it's insane. We
made 2 mil in as little as a minute and
53 seconds. Now obviously it took time
to buy these offers find the prices. I
mean in total maybe I messed around with
it for 7 8 minutes. But I mean
nonetheless really really insane method
and if you're just you know quick about
it and go to the GE and check once and
don't make a video on it you know could
be a little bit more efficient for you.
But hopefully you guys found that is a
pretty entertaining method. Now, there
may be other margins you might want to
work with there. Now, after this video
comes out, obviously going to be dead
margins for a little bit. Just give it
some time. I promise it always comes
back. But if I mean, if you find other
items that work there that I didn't say
in this video, feel free to check them
out, too, because you know, maybe they
might have better margins. Nonetheless,
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video. If
you guys did, make sure to leave a like.
On top of that, make sure to enter into
the bond giveaway down below. Just
comment your RS name. And in addition,
if you guys enjoy the videos, make sure
to subscribe to be alerted as soon as
future videos go live.